cela peut sembler paradoxal mais en
pleine crise sanitaire cette société
d'ambulance privée basé à guyancourt a
vu son activité baisser dès le début du
confinement moins de patients notamment
en raison des ehpad fermé par rapport à
l'activité normale
disons que dans la journée il y avait
des creux parce qu'en fait tout ce qui
était obligé comme les dialyses tout ça
les sorties des petites d'urgence et
sans parler du coville qui à part on a
quand même eu un ralentissement au fossé
une normale vers un ralentissement quand
même on peut dire qu'on a eu plus de
coupure dans la journée que d'habitude
l'entreprise compte une vingtaine de
salariés seuls 60 % de l'effectif a été
maintenu pour intervenir six jours sur
sept
parmi les missions d'urgence le
transport de personnes suspectées d'être
atteintes du coc vie de 19
une mission qui prend beaucoup plus de
temps en raison des précautions
sanitaires
ils partent pour le
pour un mieux surtout pour millions le
samu donc il ne faut ni sur les
matériels des kits nécessaires et 2 mio
il porte à l'intervention il faut que
ces faits donc on revient encore une
fois à millau pour rebelote donc pour
faire la désinfection des véhicules
jeter tous les le kit une intervention
plus compliqué ce qui n'empêche pas
l'entreprise chaque vendredi de faire le
tour des hôpitaux yvelinois pour rendre
hommage aux soignants
[Musique]